-As I mentioned earlier
in the show,
"The Exorcist: Believer"
just opened,
and we want to know
what the people
are saying about the movie,
so we sent our writer
Mike Hanford to the theater
to see what you guys think
about "The Exorcist: Believer."
Check it out.
-Thanks, Jimmy.
I'm here at the movies
to see what the public
has to say about
"The Exorcist: Believer."
[ Quirky music plays ]
♪♪
Turn down the "Dol-bye"!
All right. What'd
you think of the movie?
-It was great.
-What was the scariest part?
-When she was getting
lifted up, like...
-Ohh! I was shaking.
I couldn't believe that.
-It was, like,
making my heart beat.
Like,
"What's gonna happen next?"
-Same. What'd you guys
think of the movie?
-There were some good
jump-scares in there.
-I drank so much ginger ale
during this movie,
I had to go
to the bathroom twice.
What was the scariest part
of the movie to you guys?
-The earthquake
at the beginning.
I actually was, "Oh, no, oh --"
the whole time.
-I heard you say that
in the theater!
-You did?
-Yeah. Didn't you hear me say,
"Shut up!"?
I understand you do
a very good impression
of The Exorcist.
-[ Deep voice] I don't know
what you're talking about.
Shut up.
Uh, um, uh -- [ Laughs ]
-At any point in the movie,
did you think
a dracula was gonna show up?
-No, no.
-I didn't, either.
How would you rank this movie,
on a scale from 1
to awesome sauce?
-Buffalo sauce.
-Buffalo sauce!
"Awesome sauce" on 3.
One, two, three --
-Awesome sauce!
-All right!
Awesome sauce.
I --
♪♪
-That's good to hear.
Good to hear what people
thought of the movie.
Thank you very much,
Mike Hanford.